welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Rebels season 2. whether you've
watched Rebels or not we are doing this
four-part re-watch series to break down
the Easter eggs of plot points and the
tie-ins to the larger Star Wars Universe
of this Animated Series so that you can
go into titles like Ahsoka as somewhat
of an expert and at the end of this
breakdown I'm going to give you a bit of
a cheat sheet with the most useful stuff
you need to know coming out of this
season going into Ahsoka please
subscribe to the break room because
that's going to be where our upcoming
Ahsoka after show Wookie leaks is and
you're going to want to stick with us
for these Eight Episodes of Ahsoka all
right let's get started Rebel season two
episodes one and two the siege of the
lothal parts one and two the ghost crew
now works for the rebel Phoenix Squadron
led by John Sato and including Ahsoka
Tano Ezra you will notice still has his
scar from he and kanan's fight with The
Inquisitor and this is one finale just a
bit of nice continuity for this series
that it sticks with as it continues just
to show Ezra's brushes with the dark
side stay with him Lord Vader shakes
down Minister Tua and we get a close-up
of his outstretched hand gesturing
toward to us seen by kallus like he
knows his high ranking wizard is known
to force stroke officers and this season
we start to see how kallus starts to
have second thoughts about his loyalties
Tua reaches out to the rebels to defect
offering a list of Rebel synthesizers on
lothal and the true reason the emperor
cares about lothal but to its shuttle
explodes and Vader blames the rebels and
the Bridger home is destroyed Ezra also
later sees tarkentown another possible
Refuge going up in smoke so like Luke
Skywalker and Star Wars you can't go
home again as they try to escape Ezra
and Kanan since a cold presence and boom
Vader red lightsaber same Posey strikes
in the Rogue one kill box he takes it to
Ezra and Kanan one-handed and he seems
to just be playing with him but why
really he wants them to escape so that
he can track them to the rest of the
Rebel Fleet which brings us to this
crucial moment when Vader turns to look
out of his cockpit since scene oh
prisons he hasn't felt since and this
moment is so good the fear the anger the
hate
[Music]
The Apprentice lives
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate leads to Vader she
assumed Anakin was dead this season
shows Ahsoka in denial of this truth
that Anakin is the same person as Vader
and I don't think she really believes it
until she actually sees that face
beneath the mask in the season finale
Vader communicates with Palpatine voiced
here by Sam Whitworth and he tells the
emperor that the apprentices Skywalker
lives
is an opportunity and cannot let pass
Skywalker's Apprentice could lead us to
other lost Jedi such as Kenobi yeah
quite a few promises made here for the
season Vader Ahsoka rematch whitworth's
voice tells us that the animated version
of maul may be in the works and someday
later in this series we'll get the
return of
it episode 3 The Lost commanders Ahsoka
sends a ghost crew to steal a system to
find somebody that she used to know Rex
former clone trooper from the 500 person
later the 332nd companies recurring
companion to Ahsoka Tano and Anakin and
Kenobi and Clone Wars he's joined by
Gregor and wolf Gregor's shirt has a
power sliders logo on it power sliders
was a diner on avafar where Gregor was a
dishwasher for a bit Gregor agrees to
help them find a base location if they
use Devas Bay to catch a jupa that's a
giant worm creature that they could feed
on for a year this scene where they
catch it totally and homage to Jaws
Kanan doesn't trust clones after Order
66 of course but Rex says that they
never betray the Jedi because they
remove their control chips and you can
see a scar on their heads from where
those chips were surgically removed
moved a process that we see on Rex in
the Clone Wars season 7 finale Rex tells
Ezra a great Jedi once told me that the
best leaders lead by example something
that must have been said to him by
Anakin when Rex served under his
commander in the Clone Wars but wolf
ratted them out an imperial drone
damages the Phantom episode 4 relics of
the Old Republic stranded on steelos Rex
offers a few possible Rebel based sites
and the other two are like you know what
I'm actually done with war agent kallus
arrives with atat's or at ATS on the
horizon an homage to how these things
were first introduced on Hoth and Empire
Strikes Back Ezra uses a force to see
through a sandstorm and Fires at a weak
point on the Walkers the callus almost
finishes them
just like the old days yeah just like
the old days Clone Wars Rex is back we
made a new Inquisitor here the fifth
brother his design was actually inspired
by unused artwork for the force awakens
we saw the live action version of the
fifth brother in Obi-Wan Kenobi played
by Sun Kang the rebels escaped steelos
where Rex reunites with Ahsoka later it
was confirmed that Gregor and wolf
actually stayed behind and made that
last AT-AT their new home Dave filoni
confirmed that there was a deleted scene
that showed this episode 5 always two
there are of course a reference to
Yoda's line about the Sith and Phantom
Menace the Sith rule of two which comes
back in the Sith temple in malachor this
season here it refers to two inquisitors
the fifth brother and the seventh sister
who's voiced by Sarah Michelle Geller
Kanan actor Freddie Prince Jr's wife
Ezra Sabine and Zeb and Shopper take the
Phantoms gets medical supplies from an
Old Republic medical base it's kind of a
scene straight out of aliens Chopper
encounters an 99 secret Droid pet that
belongs to the seventh sister fifth
brother captures Sabine seven sister
captures interrogates Ezra about Ahsoka
Zeb and Chopper rescue Ezra and Sabine
and Escape back to the rebel Fleet where
Kanan is shocked to learn about these
new inquisitors how many are there
episode six brothers of the broken horn
Rex and Kanan trained Ezra they butt
heads over whether one should be a
soldier or a Jedi Ezra says he's not
sure if he wants to be either because
our dude is in a mood a distressed call
comes from visago ship remember him from
season one the ship is called the broken
horn which has actually been taken over
by Hondo onaka The Pirates Who also
appeared in the Clone Wars voiced by Jim
Cummings you can also see this character
on the Disneyland Galaxy's Edge ride
Smugglers Run he claims vizago lost his
ship to him in a game of an imperial
ship attacks and Chopper and Ezra
fixership just in time to jump to
hyperspace Ezra agrees to help a knocker
with a deal they talk about the planet
Nix is to deliver the goods to a buyer
as Morgan you remember him in the Nexus
Hub you can see a bunch of posters on
the walls including one for the Imperial
Navy that reads the shape of freedom and
protecting the Galaxy with strength and
Justice there's also an ad for the blue
milk that every Star Wars fan knows and
a poster that reads leave it in
hyperdrive Ezra's screwing around with a
knock in this episode really helps him
realize that the life of a thief and a
Smuggler is less appealing to him than
the discipline of being a Jedi but is it
the discipline or the Power episode 7
wings of the master sure Kanan the
Phoenix Squadron try bringing some food
to the oppressed people of ibar Rex
brings up a prototype blockade Buster
that they can find in Santa Paul Harris
Sabine and Zeb get through Santa Paul's
tricky atmosphere in the mon calamari
engineer Quarry saves them from falling
off an edge of the cliff Cory also
appears in the Animated Series Lego Star
Wars the free maker Adventures Corey
shows them this blockade Buster called
the blade Wing this ship would
eventually become the b-wing a fighter
seen in the original trilogy didn't get
a lot of screen time though Hera takes
control of the b-wing Sabine tells Corey
that she'll fix the blade Wings laser
aiming system never get between a
Mandalorian and a weapons package yeah
something to know about Sabine as a
former Imperial weapons expert she just
loves to blow up the success of
this Mission gets Hera promoted to
Phoenix Squadron leader episode 8 blood
sisters so Sabine Ezra and Chopper head
to the Havoc Outpost to intercept a
courier which ends up being the Droid
eg86 Sabine reunites with an old friend
turned Bounty Hunter ketsu onyo voiced
by Gina Torres a firefly Fame ketsu
works for a crime syndicate black son
and she's seeking out the EG Droid
through ketsu we see what sabine's life
could have looked like if she didn't
join their Rebellion we learned that a
pension to blow up goes further
when there's an imperial Crest on that
episode 9 is stealth strike Ezra
and Commander Sado are captured by an
imperial interdictor light Cruiser which
creates a gravity weld strong enough to
pull ships out of hyperspace whoa this
is the episode that many of us single
out to accuse Chopper of being a war
criminal because this episode ends with
chopper sabotaging that ship so that it
explodes and takes out two Imperial
Cruisers with it which some estimates
online have put from around 4 500 total
deaths to maybe 47 000 deaths I don't
know I think it's probably on the lower
end of that but either way that's a lot
of people now you could say that Luke
Skywalker blew up the Death Star that's
a lot of Stormtroopers but the Death
Star was just about to blow up the rebel
base they were totally justified they
were acting in defense Chopper meanwhile
did not need to kill this many people
okay episode 10 the future of the force
this episode is the first one to take
place in three BBY we're moving ahead in
time here folks closer and closer to the
events of A New Hope Ahsoka realizes
that details about Vader are just kind
of hard to find hmm why is that she
comes to a civilian transport that was
wiped out by the seventh sister in the
fifth brother and they go in a rescue
mission to recover some Force sensitive
kids Ahsoka mentions a past incident
where Force sensitive kids were taken
during the Clone Wars this is a
reference to Clone Wars season 2 episode
3 Children of the forest where darcitius
sent CAD Bane after some kids and so
after swearing off the Jedi Order we see
that Ahsoka has to return to Our
obligation to the four seizures that are
out there in the universe which adds to
her guilt that had she not left Anakin
and the order maybe maybe Anakin might
not have fallen to the dark side and
Order 66 wouldn't have been as effective
okay episode 11 Legacy this episode
aired on December 9 2015 making it the
last Rebels Episode to air before the
force awakens and the sequel Trilogy
just kind of took everything over Ezra
dreams about his parents in Imperial
prison and Harry and Kanan mentioned
hearing about a prison break the group
splits up Ezra and Kate into the Phantom
to lothal the restain and gorill with
the ghost to help fend off the imps and
Ezra follows the loath cat that he saw
on his stream and I'm telling you loot
cats are just the best and he meets
another prisoner writer Azadi voiced by
Clancy Brown who tells Ezra that his
parents heard his broadcast from season
one and that inspired them to organize
their prison break but they died in the
break out so Kanan Comforts it by
telling him that his parents live inside
him but it's kind of a mixed rite of
passage for Ezra while it definitely
hardens his resolve it also Saddles him
with some survivor's guilt and reminders
of some personal ties in his life that
just makes him more vulnerable to the
dark side okay episode 12 a princess on
both all the Leia episode Bill Organa
picks his daughter Lance top the rebels
to secure some much needed Cruisers But
It's tricky because while the ghosts
crew are all public criminals Leia and
Bale are still pretending to be
diplomatically neutral Leia is voiced
here by Julie Dolan who also voices Leia
in some video games and on the Star
Tours ride at Disney the plan is a
success and the rebels steal the three
Cruisers and Leia is able to blame the
Imperials for their failure to protect
them and inspired by this writer izadi
joins the rebel cause Okay episode 13
the protector of conquer Dawn this is an
important episode for the Mandalorian
side of Star Wars titles as Concord Dawn
is one of the moons of Mandalore and the
rebels run into the Mandalorian faction
called the protectors they're led by
Finn Rao a former pilot instructor that
Kanan knows from the Battle of my Guido
this was in an issue of the Star Wars
Canon comic the symbol on Finn Rouse
helmet is based on Joe Johnston's
original designs for Boba Fett before
the making of The Empire Strikes Back
felony named the character after Brad
Rao director of this episode and a bunch
of other Star Wars animated stuff
including resistance in the bad batch
they pilot Fang Fighters these ships
would also appear in the Mandalorian
season 3 in chapters 23 and 24 and we
learned that these mandalorians have
sided with the Empire that's right the
Mandalorian factions have some diverse
loyalties which will be important to
Sabine in season 3. savine reveals to
the protectors that she is from house
Vizsla and she challenges Rao to single
combat working together Kanan and Sabine
capture Rao and he agrees to allow the
rebels safe Passage through conquer done
but we learned that even the ghost crew
could be divided by their past loyalties
and their past lives before the
Rebellion episode 14 Legends of the
lasat the ghost crew arrives to nyx's
HUB 218 this is the same world that we
saw in the brothers of the broken horn
they rescue a pair of lassats Chava the
wise and gron so Zeb ain't the last of
his species that's good news these two
are seeking the mystical world of lira's
son where surviving lasates can find
Refuge Zeb transforms his bow rifle into
its true form and combines it with
Chavez staff revealing lirison's
location in the Uncharted wild space Zeb
decides to stay with the ghost crew to
continue looking for lasates another
Rebel choose and stick with a rebellion
rather than another life that they could
live but this is the episode that the
ancient names of the sides of the force
are first revealed by Chava calling the
light side ashla and the dark side Bogan
these get repeated by the bendu in a
later episode of rebels we'll get to him
later but these terms actually come from
early treatments of the first Star Wars
film by George Lucas and ahsoka's name
in early development for Clone Wars is
actually ashla and ashla is the name
that she later takes on as an alias
during her Exile during e.k Johnston's
novel episode 15 the call this is the
first appearance of the pergol I
mentioned the pilot episode that the
sound of the force that Ezra heard
sounds like a whale call
a possible Pergo out there and he meets
them here Pergo will play an important
role in the final episode of the series
they show up in live action in chapter
17 of the Mandalorian as well as Ahsoka
her girl consumed the klauson 36 gas in
the atmosphere to power their ability to
jump into hyperspace during this mission
to capture fuel from the mining Guild
Ezra and Kanan help these Pergo and Ezra
forms a special bond with these
creatures that will pay off later so all
of us have bad habits we just get used
to them so that we stop noticing that
we're constantly biting our fingernails
down to the nub or whatever it is but
there's good news you can turn your bad
habits into good ones using fume Doom is
an Innovative award-dominated device
with no electronics no vapor and no
harmful chemicals Doom is completely
natural it uses all natural ingredients
to give you a burst of delicious
flavored air I mean having spilled these
cores they just do smell very pleasant
and nice it feel makes it possible to
have a habit you are free to enjoy it
makes replacing your bad habit easy Doom
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable parts and
magnets and it's super fidgety which is
helpful for de-stressing while you break
your old habit using the fume is like
having a breath of fresh minty air that
get this tastes even better than a
freshly bitten fingernail swishing to
fume is easy over 100 000 people have
used fume to successfully break out of
bad habits and now you can too head to
trifum.com and use code new rockstars to
save 10 off when you get the journey
packed today that's try fum.com and use
code new rockstars to save an additional
10 off your order today episode 16
homecoming so this is an important Hera
episode we visit the twilik home of the
rylot system that first appeared in
flashback in the Clone Wars season one
episode Jedi crash we meet Hera's father
champ cindula a clone wars hero with the
nickname of the Liberator of ryloth his
first appearance was in the Clone Wars
episode Liberty on ryloth father and
daughter argue and we hear Hera's twilik
accent come through here I am part of
something bigger Jam only cares about
the twilik resistance and not the
overall Rebel cause so he just wants to
bomb the Imperial carrier while Hera
wants to capture it so that the rebels
can use it but they do get to blow up an
Imperial Star Destroyer so you know Cham
does get his show of Force episode 17
The Honorable ones so we return to
Geonosis that's the planet from Attack
of the Clones where they learn the
geologian insectoid species are all dead
why well because Palpatine ordered the
genocide of the geonosians to keep
secret the construction of the Death
Star oh my God Zeb and kallus get
stranded together on a cave on a nearby
ice Moon they run into a bone zombie
creature which gets its name from the
Zamboni this is an important episode for
kallus who admits to Zeb here that he
respects the lasata's Warriors and he
didn't agree with the Empire's decision
to exterminate them and that the bow
rifle he previously claimed to have
stolen from a deadless odd Honor Guard
was actually given to him by that guard
after he defeated him in an honorable
duel the two leave each other with a
mutual respect and they nearly started
kissing I would say but that coldness
that kallus felt on this moon was
nothing compared to the coldness that
greeted him back on his Imperial Star
Destroyer our man's got dots episode 18
shroud of Darkness okay so all Jedi
Temple or Sith Temple episodes are must
watches this one's no different Kanan
and Ezra battle the seventh sister and
fifth brother because Chopper I guess
forgot to pick them up they're on usalan
and Ezra and Kanan are saved by the
tibetes you remember these guys seven
sister says such a handsome face I don't
go for crazy anymore yeah it's a fun
husband and wife exchange between the
Geller and Prince Ahsoka watches the
recording of Anakin
adjustments to the classic form 4
techniques so form four also known as
ataru is one of the seven forms of
lightsaber combat practiced by both Jedi
and Sith it's an aggressive style that
is fast paced and effective against
single opponents the weaker and
prolonged combat in confined spaces
Anakin made some adjustments to form
four yeah because it fails him with
Dooku and this could actually explain
why Ahsoka uses two Sabers they return
to the lothal Jedi Temple and Ezra asks
Ahsoka if she wants to open it but she
says she's no longer a Jedi but because
she is with them a different deeper door
on the temple opens inside the three
split up because we are in a spiritual
sequel to last season's path of the Jedi
and it's so good Canon seeks knowledge
to defeat the inquisitors and he's
greeted in his vision by a sentinel who
is a Jedi Temple guard his double-sided
saber tells us this is gonna be a
familiar face and yes it is the UDA
power ran Inquisitor those voiced by
Jason Isaacs it's a warning that even
great Jedi can still fall to the will of
the dark side so keep an eye on Ezra
Ezra meanwhile meets with Yoda more than
just his voice this time we actually see
Yoda as he communes with Ezra from the
swamps of digobot he shows Ezra a near
shot for shot Recreation the closing
shots of attack of the Clones and he
tells Ezra defined malachor for Ahsoka
Matt Lanter returns as Anakin in this
episode
where were you when I needed you
what I've become
yeah our girl cannot accept it they
escape an attack from the inquisitors
who are able to access his Temple
because they are former Jedi the fifth
brother says that the Jedi are growing
in their power and Vader replies it will
be their undoing true true okay episode
19 the Forgotten Droid in episode 20 The
Mystery of the chopper base they are
both fun but Filler episodes from Rebel
season two I'd say all you really need
to know about these is that in episode
20 they do run into some krikna ice
spiders like the ones danger and grogu
run into in Mando season two okay here
we go the two final episodes episode 21
and episode 22 Twilight of The
Apprentice part one and part two so Ezra
Ahsoka and Kanan go to malachor which
they say has always been off limits to
the Jedi and yeah no Ahsoka says
there's always a bit of Truth in Legends
I love this line so many ways to read it
truth and legends AKA expanded universe
material truth and legends like ahsoka's
experience and mortis truth and
legendary figures like Maul and truth
and the legends of the Sith Hoover
thousands of years were really the
dominant class of force wielders
malcolor was actually first alluded to
back in 2004 in Star Wars Knights of the
Old Republic 2 the Sith Lords it's where
the dark side of the force runs strong
approaching this planet the trios see
these large black structures almost
reminiscent of the black monolith in
2001 A Space Odyssey they Judd out of
the planet I gotta say the design Style
Just way better than the Jedi style but
the Sith Temple appears like a pyramid
just like the holocron that Ezra will
later obtain Dave filoni has said in
interviews that they designed the Sith
Temple to have red glowing lines at the
base to look like veins because they
want the Sith temples and Jedi temples
to feel like sentient creatures in their
own right the three of them find this
battlefield where Sith and Jedi fought
thousands of years ago the Jedi hoping
to stop a Sith super weapon the Sith
activated that weapon and they turned
all these living beings into Pompeii
like Stone now this is actually inspired
a kind of Sith drug called ashes of
malachor which allows consumers to
increase their ties to the dark side and
power at the cost of their own mortality
Maul is actually seen inhaling some
ashes of malachor in the second issue of
the comic book series Darth Maul number
two that was in 2017. Ezra picks up a
broken cross guard lightsaber with a
green blade this episode came out a few
months after the force awakens so this
gave some historical Credence to kylo
Ren's blade design the eighth brother a
new Inquisitor has been stalking them
and it keeps like fighting them and then
being like hey you better come chase me
meanwhile Ezra meets this old man who
calls himself old Master this is
actually Maul Voice by Sam wentwor who
of course voiced a character in Clone
Wars so awesome to have him back when
this episode came out in 2016 the last
time we had seen Maul wasn't Clone Wars
season 5 after his seizure of Mandalore
with the death watch when he had the
darksaber and he was left tortured and
taken by Sidious who at this point had
replaced him with Dooku and soon after
that replaced in Duke with Anakin now
later Clone Wars scene 7 would show
Maul's return to Mandalore after his
escape from Sidious his duel with Ahsoka
and his Escape during Order 66 so yeah
right now our guy hates the Empire Ezra
also uses an alias when he talks to him
names himself Jabba which Maul can't
help but laugh at because he did meet
the real Jabba the Hut in Clone Wars
episode Eminence when Maul was head of
the Shadow Collective the Sith Temple
requires two Jedi to lift the stones
together and two to ascend the pyramid
at any given time reflecting of course
the Sith rule of two which Maul tries to
use to isolate himself with his and
manipulate Ezra's pain your anger is a
Wellspring you must use it your passions
give you strength
improve strength you'll gain power you
have seen it you feel it you must break
your chains Marlin as refiner said
holocron now this hologram has a small
inscription that translates into Latin
in umbrous protesters or in the shadows
there is power Maul uses the holocron to
open doors a metaphor for the doors to
the dark side it can unlock the three
inquisitors unite and they recognized
ball as the shadow which is kind of
their way saying Omar common Keenan
Ezra and Ahsoka and Maul versus the
three inquisitors the lightsaber dueling
is so great in this finale Mall four
strokes and kills the 7th sister Maul
sees something moving on the surface
blocking out the light from above it's a
literal walking Shadow definitely Vader
approaching the fifth brother goes down
the eighth brother Falls when his spinny
blade breaks but to his death probably
we're not exactly sure probably Mall
blinds Kanan oh my God now this
blindness is actually part of the
character design from the start because
in a now deleted tweet lucasfilms Pablo
Hidalgo said that Kanan and another
blind Jedi character Ram Kota from the
Legends Canon were both inspired by
zatuichi who is a prominent fictional
character in Japanese pop culture Ezra
reaches the top of the pyramid and
activates the holocron it activates the
presence which is a disembodied
intelligence taken in the form of pink
and purple lightning it is a female
presenting voice played by actress Nika
futterman the presence is the last
remains of a female Sith who once
commanded the super weapon housed in the
Sith Temple this present says knowledge
it is power Kanan reaches for a mask
left behind by one of these Jedi to
battle Maul literally there is truth and
legends here he uses this and the force
to defeat Maul the presence tells Ezra
that she's been waiting to unleash her
power at his command when Ezra refuses
she says that perhaps the other who
approaches will claim it but it's not
Maul it's Vader it's Vader versus Ezra
Vader says then you will die braver than
most but Ahsoka intervenes and Ahsoka
finally admits what she's been denying
all season and this exchange is so great
panic in the Skywalker was weak I
destroyed him
I will avenge his death revenge is not
the Jedi way I am no Jedi yes Ahsoka
transforms her guilt for leaving the
Jedi Order for leaving Anakin into a new
power to go further than the Jedi
Orthodoxy restraint would allow her to
go they start fighting meanwhile blind
Kanan arrives to Chopper adorably
holding his hand the master and
Apprentice removed the holocron together
Ahsoka holds Vader back Ahsoka slices
Vader's helmet and underneath oh my God
we see Vader's face now it includes an
eyebrow the eyebrow supposed to be
burned off but they use this because
they use Anakin's 3D animation model
from the lightsaber tutorial earlier and
listen to this we hear Ahsoka mixed in
with Matt lanter's voice and James Earl
Jones voice
but as he transitions to then you will
die it is just one voice then you will
die the temple collapses as they duel we
don't learn until later how Ahsoka got
through her battle with Vader but as
Vader steps out of the ruins we do see
ahsoka's more eye bird from the mortise
Arc and Clone Wars the final shot of the
season shows Ezra with the red light of
the Sith holocron reflected in his eyes
like that scar on his face his brush
with the dark side leaves a mark okay
coming on to season two here's a bit of
a cheat sheet for you the must watch
episodes all them watch all of them
they're all fun all fun but if you only
have time for a few just the temple
episodes episode 18 shroud of Darkness
21-22 Twilight of The Apprentice okay
stand out moment of the Season Ahsoka
encountering Anakin for the first time
since he became Darth Vader neither knew
the other was alive until now their
malachor rematch one for the ages Ahsoka
saying I am no Jedi and we'll come back
to this moment later in the series we
meet a few more inquisitors they don't
last beyond this season we learned that
ghost cruise backstories and kallus is
now warming up to Zeb Maul is back baby
and he's taking a keen interest in Ezra
and we have to remember the whole
history of Jedi temples and Sith temples
Sith used to be the dominant class of
Force wielders if anyone has a claim to
history it's them not the Jedi the Jedi
are the aberration in the anomaly and
that is why the dark side of the force
is far more potent okay you can support
us with one of these Star Wars inspired
baseball tees they are awesome please
subscribe to all three of our channels
especially the break room because that's
where our Ahsoka after shows are going
to be you can follow me on all social
platforms at EA boss following the
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]